hello and welcome to the shaky science
show where in this video I'm going to
discuss some recent data I've come from
a human troll whereby they had
participants take niacin for four to ten
months to see if it could help treat
patients with mitochondrial myopathy
so I'll discuss what all of these
different terms mean and discussed their
data and say this data was recently
published in the Cell Metabolism paper
that came out just the other day and is
titled niacin kills systemic NAD+
deficiency and improves muscle
performance and adult onset
mitochondrial myopathy say before I go
into the results that they saw and some
of the side effects of the study I'll
just explain what some of these terms
mean so if I say let's talk about niacin
because I've never spoken about it on
this channel in any detail before so
niacin is also referred to as vitamin b3
or nicotinic acid and it can be found
lots of different food types such as
meats fish legumes and seeds all nicing
can be taken as supplements so nice and
it's best known as being a precursor to
nad nicotinamide adenine dinucleotide
and they spoke about the metabolism of
NAD+ before in this channel and look how
complicated it is but the Sun was just
gonna focus on the reads of niacin into
nad class so the current mechanism
linking niacin to nad plus formation is
the priests handler pathway sir if I
said that wrong and is named after the
founders of the pathway and impose
firstly nice and conversion into
nicotinic acid mono nucleotides and then
into nicotinic acid dinucleotide and
then nad plus and so why do we care so
much about nad plus well it's one of the
most abundant molecules in the body and
is a really important cofactor for two
major functions one of which is acting
as a redox coenzyme
and the other is acting as a substrate
for nad requiring enzymes so when this
clinical trial they were using niacin to
see if it has an impact on alleviating
the symptoms of mitochondrial myopathy
so why did they focus on a mitochondrial
disease
well the mitochondria
is an organelle in the cell that
performs every bit respiration and is
actually a key regulator of the NAD+ to
the reduced form of NAD+ NADH ratio so
the mitochondrial disease that they
focused on was mitochondrial myopathy
and so this disease is characterized by
a progressive weakness of eye muscles
but also in general you see decline in
wasty muscle weakness and fatigue
ability and the major cause of this
disease seen in adults is to see the
accumulation of mutations in the DNA
that's found in the mitochondria yes
that's right you don't only have DNA in
the nucleus and so these mutations are
often deletions and so the push towards
the human clinical trials here is due to
the positive benefits they've already
seen in mouse studies so by increasing
the NAD+ levels and mouse models of
mitochondrial myopathy they saw an
improvement and my total dysfunction and
increase muscle strength and so in this
study they wanted to see what would
happen if they treated human patients
live nice and to try and increase the
NAD+ levels and so the setup of this
clinical trial was between four and ten
months for the patients and the controls
and they increased the dose throughout
the time as i written up here and say
for the patients they did it for ten
months and the controls only for four
months and the patients there was five
of them there was one male and four
females aged between 17 and 70 and for
the controls they were age and sex
matched and they were healthy so the
first thing they needed to check was
whether or not having nice and actually
increased the NAD+ levels because that
was the main rationale behind their
methods so firstly they looked at the
NAD+ levels in the muscle tissue and for
this a tips and biopsy samples and so in
the patients at four months in ten
months they saw an increase in the
muscle NAD+ levels at one point three
folds and a two point three fold
increase and by ten months has actually
matched the healthy control
which they didn't see an increase
throughout the study even by taking
niacin so besides looking at the muscle
NAD+ levels they also looked at the
blood NAD+ levels and they saw an
increase in both the controls and the
patients this time with a 7.1 fold
increased by four months in the patients
and a 5.7 fold increase in the controls
and so obviously that's proved that nice
and worked at increasingly NAD+ levels
but the other question of the study is
whether or not actually helps with the
symptoms of mitochondrial myopathy but I
think it's a key thing to point out here
that this was from looking at the Bloods
and 80-plus levels and this is
potentially good as a diagnostic because
the EnergyPlus levels were lower in the
mitochondrial myopathy patients than the
controls to begin with in the study so
it could be a good diagnostic for people
with the condition and it's a good way
to track the effects of niacin
throughout the study so so far they've
proved that niacin is a powerful NAD+
booster in humans both in healthy
patient controls and patients but
doesn't help with the symptoms so to do
this one of the things they looked at is
whether or not they could restore muscle
strength so one thing I haven't actually
mentioned yet which might just be of
interest is why yuuji see a decrease in
muscle strength when you have these
mutations and the mitochondria and
that's mainly because the muscles such
an energetic tissue and so it's
vulnerable to defects in the
mitochondrial metabolism anyway back to
the results so they saw increase in some
of the muscles such as they have to run
a muscle the back muscle short muscles
and knee although these were to varying
effects but unfortunately they didn't
see an improvement in the ocular muscles
which they think is G's the fact that
this is one of the first muscles to
become defective during mitochondrial
myopathy
so what are they see in the healthy
controls well they also saw some slight
increase in shoulder strength and the
extension despite the fact that the NAD+
levels in the muscle didn't actually
increase so what other effects that they
see so interestingly they saw a decrease
in the patient to PASOK and fiscal fat
otherwise referred to as the unhealthy
fats
and they think that this could be due to
the fact that from the improvements and
mitochondrial performance they see
increased oxidative phosphorylation
which is aerobic respiration which could
explain the increased metabolism and use
of the fats there wasn't a corresponding
reduction in this unhealthy fat in the
controls although they did see a
whole-body reduction in the fat
percentage and in terms of the
mitochondria itself and the patients
whilst they saw an improvement they
didn't actually see any changes in the
structure of the mitochondria or any
change in the deletion load so besides
these positive effects that they saw
there were also some side effects
reported and one of which is a reduction
in hemoglobin which I'll come back to in
just a minute so side effects seen in
all of the patients included hot flushes
and a tingling tingling cycling fear
tingling sensation of extremities when
they were taking more than 500
milligrams per day of Nisan but as I
said they also saw a reduction in
hemoglobin which is the oxygen carrying
compound that's found in red blood cells
that delivers oxygen around your body
and they also saw a decrease in the red
blood cell number so this is important
to consider for the longevity of these
studies and they also saw own
gastrointestinal irritation such that
two controls actually dropped out and
then other side effects reported
included skin drying and flatulence
lovely so what can we actually take away
from these results so far well this
study very much shows that niacin is
effective at increasing the NAD+ levels
and the benefits that basal with the
mitochondrial myopathy patients is
thought to be by a metabolic bypass
because they see these improvements in
the metabolic functions without seeing
improvements in the DNA deletion of the
mitochondrial DNA but the problem is
this is only there was only five
patients they need to do it in a larger
trial size I also try and see what the
optimal dose is to try and minimize
these side effects but I think overall
this has been
exciting study so far obviously it's
been done in patience and if you go into
the clinical trial website which I'll
link in a description you can see more
detail about the different measurements
that they took so hopefully this was
useful and as always thanks for
listening